I received in the wake of the Donald
Trump presidential election the vilest
hate mail that I believe I've ever
received and if you look at my hate mail
folder there are thousands upon
thousands of emails in there I'm gonna
show it to you in a second the back
story of this entire situation is Donald
Trump is one thing right but the violent
and dangerous racists and xenophobes who
have been in bold and by Donald Trump's
election as president elect are another
thing they are very disturbing and a top
concern for all sorts of civil rights
groups across the country up we're going
to get into some of the broader data but
I want to give you just this first data
point case in point this is the vilest
hate mail I've probably ever received
and I receive a lot and this is just one
example of the many that have come in
after Donald Trump was elected this is
very aggressive I'm just warning you we
are gonna put it up on the screen some
viewers may find this very disturbing
and I will read it to you let's take a
look at it Pat this was an email from
somebody uh using the email address
gasps a [ __ ] at hotmail.com probably a
fake email address uh these email
addresses often just put in there as
part of the entire thing the subject
racist anti white [ __ ] fail to stop
Trump and it was from someone calling
themselves kaikki [ __ ] Steen the message
to me you are nothing but an inbred [ __ ]
gas chamber rat Pakman no one listened
to the SF Jew media this election and no
one ever will again everyone is now
aware of you [ __ ] promoting white
genocide you are effing finished Jew boy
enjoy your new president also over the
weekend I was home in western
Massachusetts racist anti-semitic pro
truck Trump graffiti appeared on a cliff
side in East Hampton Massachusetts on
the cliff side on Mount tom significant
outrage from local residents a bunch of
my friends showed up and actually uh
painted over it it said everything from
gas the Jews uh kill all black people
without using that word from 2016 and
swastikas also some
friends of mine in Greenfield
Massachusetts this is this is a very
liberal area where there were enclaves
of Trump support but by and large a very
liberal area uh reporting that not far
from uh really right next to a synagogue
in the Greenfield Massachusetts area a
swastika carved into the sidewalk
Department of Public Works reportedly
came out and uh grounded down so many
people reaching out and expressing
concern for number one Jews because it's
very very popular to just start blaming
Jews attacking Jews etcetera despite the
fact by the way that for the I think for
the first time we have members of the
first family who will be Jewish
under a Donald Trump administration this
proves again it's only partially about
Trump but is mostly about who's
emboldened by Trump and number two
concern for people in progressive media
as well a lot of people over the weekend
talking to me about that I told you
about the incident in Philadelphia at a
Jewish owned business uh something like
Heil Trump 2016 with swastikas on the
glass window at the front and there have
been more than 200 incidents of hateful
harassment or intimidation which are
anti-semitic in nature reported so far
pad to the Southern Poverty Law Center
it's just been hours in truck since
Trump's election this is very scary
stuff yeah I'm shocked that this sort of
thing could happen in Western
Massachusetts because when you think of
Western Massachusetts it's a very quaint
nice progressive area yeah so it is
surprising but there's been so much
coverage over the protests the
anti-trump protesting going on over the
past week or so yeah better by a large
nonviolent peaceful I'm worried about
the the more racist voices that are
empowered under a trump presidency they
are feeling emboldened they're feeling
very emboldened that email I got is only
bill it we can't do an entire show where
I just read hate mail but this was so
particularly spiteful and vile and
aggressive that I I thought we would
included in our discussion today of what
are right this is not just me getting
this stuff we have a report from the ADL
about the violent and aggressive uh uh
attacks via Twitter on and and what I
mean is linguistically violent obviously
you can't do physical violence via
Twitter although you can incite it
against Jewish journalists and reporters
including Ben Shapiro who is a
right-wing
who did not support Donald Trump this is
getting really really serious and we're
going to keep covering it